things are picking up in Europe's
biggest economy more jobs more growth
and higher wages and the German
government expects things to get even
better over the next two years the
economy is forecast to grow by one point
eight percent this year and it could
exceed that figure the year after
expanding by two percent in 2015 the
economics Minister used the occasion to
highlight two of his party's key
projects the introduction of a national
minimum wage and tougher rules for
companies using temporary workers before
mid winter pleased about the positive
development in wages it means demand
here in Germany is becoming our growth
engine but behind the glass risks remain
chiefly the poor economic outlook in
other parts of Europe and the danger of
bubbles in financial markets this is not
too early it's in our interest that
financial markets remain regulated live
and are more strongly regulated vahab
ins all we had justified concerns that
bubbles could develop in the markets
that could put banks into trouble
phoolon does Bank mini Chief laga
govardhan concerns that aren't likely to
spoil the appetite for spending in
Germany an appetite now shared by
consumers and companies